a party of tourists embark on a guided
walking Safari they're hoping for a
glimpse of the world's most amazing
creatures among the group are the
Crozier brothers from Durban South
Africa mark turns 34 in just a few days
and Shaun is here to help him celebrate
my brother's wife was supposed to go in
and she couldn't because she just had a
newborn baby two armed Park guides lead
the group
they spot a herd of African Buffalo on
the banks of the white in Filosa River
we could see many animals coming down to
the river leaving going backwards and
forwards is quite a busy morning
[Music]
further along the trail they spot a male
black rhinoceros in a nearby thicket
people were quite surprised and they
were quite a lot that we're so close to
the animal and it was stalling this sort
of tourist mode where you've seen the
animal and now you want to take pictures
of it the lead guide knows rhinos are
usually wary of people but this ball is
snorting and posturing aggressively male
rhinos can be more aggressive than
females he tries to scare the endangered
animal away he slept the butt of his
rifle and shot at the runner but the
runner wasn't intimidated by any of that
people didn't believe it was their
dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
the 3,000 pound Rhino charges
I thought I was relatively safe behind
this tree but this behemoth has shown in
its sights
you hit me on my upper right leg and it
felt like a truck hitting me the
tremendous blow fling Shawn high in the
air leaving him bloody and blind my
cloths were thrown into the hair so I
couldn't see anything
but I was quite aware of the smells and
the heat and the noises of the Hanul it
sounded pretty prom warning shots have
no effect on the enraged animal
it chases Shawn that suddenly turns its
sights on his brother mark
dazed and in pain from a direct blow to
the chest
mark struggles to stand but the Rhino
isn't done with them yet
it strikes him with the base of its horn
fracturing his sternum and crushing his
ribs then the Rhino wheels around and
charges another member of the group the
animal is definitely the circuit was out
of control and it was definitely going
to kill somebody
the rear guide gets a clear shot and
takes it hitting the Rhino in the side
the wounded animal disappears into the
bush leaving Shawn bruised and bloody
and mark fighting for his life
[Music]